oh he is a city that ain't very pretty
and good government as I go
but at least the raccoon infestation is
under control
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Leslie wishes she could be here herself
to give you these presents but she's
suspended oh and also she said that
they're not from her they're from Santa
Claus can I go first
mouse rat certified gold over 100 copies
sold in Pawnee
I need to get a picture of me holding
this so I can frame it personalize
leopard printed robe pink feather cuffs
and on the back in rhinestones
you can get it I know you're sad you
couldn't get tickets to The Watch the
Throne tour so I got you a watch and a
tiny Throne instead and check it out she
even took out the dumb clock part and
put this in
ball of time
these are the Black Eyed Peas
and I finally killed them
it's a Christmas miracle
every year I give Leslie the same
present I give everyone a crisp 20 bill
and every year she gets me
something thoughtful and personal it
makes me Furious
this year she outdid herself
she had it installed over the weekend
so
so beautiful
lot 48 was once a horrible and
disgusting pit and now it's the site of
pawnee's winter wonderland this could
not be more perfect if I had planned it
myself which I did
and it's awesome so let's talk sketch
guys um the kids are going to come at
9am on Saturday and everyone's going to
do Santa for two hours so I would just
advise everyone before you get in your
costume to go to the bathroom so we can
avoid what happened last year
just farts
oh hey hey I've been thinking about your
gay boyfriend all day I have got some
awesome ideas okay
first idea spray tan gift certificates
no
trip to Germany Germany is awesome
and expensive
good call
I didn't think of that okay uh you know
how people say that you should give
gifts that you would want to get
yourself what would you want
easy Indianapolis Colts Reggie Wayne
jersey number 87 double XL home blue
signed by Reggie Wayne right after he
catches a touchdown to win the Super
Bowl
okay never mind no hip-hop ABS Dance
Fitness DVD hi hi hi hi sorry I'm late I
was off getting holiday gifts for my
team William here is a nope 2012 tree
ornament hey Elizabeth I got you a nope
2012
no no okay then I got you a tree
ornament and you've been any Swanky
restaurants lately what's the occasion
it's December it's a time we celebrate
our most sacred and special event Jerry
dinner
[Music]
what the hell is Jerry dinner every time
we laugh at something stupid Jerry does
we put a dollar in this box the end of
the year we take all the cash and treat
ourselves to a fancy dinner this year we
have
516 dollars
oh jeez
and that's 517.
oh
5 18. this is how we can get gift ideas
the more she's mentioned the word the
larger it appears Ben and much larger
and
she definitely loves Anne
have an idea I will build a small wood
model of the parks department we can
decorate our offices as they are in real
life it will be
cute wait better idea
we make a gingerbread version of The
Office
my favorite Jerry moment was when he ate
a bowl of glue oh my favorite Journey
moment is when you switch down his
potato soup with glue and he didn't know
they're so cute when you're both
you know what Emma's right this is mean
we are going to pick up Jerry what no
it's Christmas time don't you want to be
good people never if we're going that
way can we stop at our place real quick
because I forgot to put on deodorant and
a jacket and one of my socks plus I
gotta poop but I can stop anywhere for
that Ron is making the model and then
we're gonna put all of our candy
decorations in our corners of the office
okay so what did everybody make boom
rock and roll Candy Andy wow that's
really good son I didn't do anything for
my office it's okay I took care of it I
made a marshmallow Ron Swanson
oh my gosh his arms are crossed because
he's mad at all the other marshmallow
workers for annoying him you like it
that's fine when I was trying to decide
how to decorate my outfits I had to ask
myself what kind of candy should I
choose obviously chocolate because I'm
sweet smooth and the ladies love me now
the questions still remained what kind
of chocolate am I do I have a little
gooey caramel Center am I filled with a
little Rice Krispies maybe I'm white
chocolate and I'm bucking all the
stereotypes put your damn candy out
ultimately I decided to go with the
little gourmet fudge I didn't have time
to make it into anything and please
don't eat it because it costs 55 an
ounce so I made my desk out of silver M
M's but they do not make silver M M's so
I spray painted them okay those are
poisonous so no one eat them yeah duh
go throw up I didn't need any go throw
up
[Music]
oh Reggie Wayne
whoa what is going on at the gargages
oh my God Jerry's having a Christmas
party I can't believe he did invite us
how dare he what do we ever do to him
it's probably just family and Ben and
Chris and Anne
I didn't even know she knew Jerry
I can handcraft 17-foot canoes out of
Western red cedar but I can't glue two
damn graham crackers together look it's
really easy I know a lot about candy I
play with it I eat it sometimes I play
with it and eat it
okay new plan everyone else makes this
candy house and I make myself useful
elsewhere
oh the garges really go all out this is
incredible
this is literally the best non-fatting
dog I've ever had
remain calm but I think you just drank
some of the regular full fat eggnog
Chris one cup won't kill you no but it
will have exactly 440 calories
but you know what
I'm fine
you only live once
I don't know if you know this but things
with fat in them taste way better than
things with no fat let us in and it's
cold outside and I can't wear mittens
because they're unflattering to my hands
sorry guys this is your penance
you can come in if you do something nice
for Jerry hey I already did something
nice for Jerry I drove here to take him
to Jerry dinner
Oh Donna you can come in okay
what's going on here Merry Christmas
Leslie we made you this replica of the
parks department out of gingerbread oh
my God I love it
I love it and I love you guys and Anne
specifically and all of you you did all
of this together yes except for me
turns out I cannot make a gingerbread
house which would bother me if I were an
eight-year-old girl hey guys I thought
you weren't coming I nope never got your
RSVP hi Jerry we got you a gift Merry
Christmas
yeah just we took up a collection to pay
your hospital bills since he almost
farted yourself to death every time we
did something mean put a dollar in a box
wow
I'm the luckiest man on Earth
okay well come on in It's a Party
jeez
[Music]
oh that's nice
hey sorry I'm late hey honey I'm so
proud of you that took guts mooning Joe
calamit so oh thanks Mom
oh God is something wrong with the tree
no nothing wrong but it's almost nine it
should have been lighted up an hour ago
we waited for you
[Music]
okay everybody count down
five
four three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]